this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu good afternoon once again
I've had a very good day today we do
some different sessions and I hope you
had a good time too we're getting to the
end of this first day of the fourth I'm
health rights conference so I hope you
enjoyed it and I hope this presentation
doesn't respond to either dr. Wallace
introduced me but I my name is Charles
of Luther McGary mola and like dr.
Wallace said I'm assistant professor of
health education at the Berlin and
Community College which is part of the
city university of new york okay um what
I'm going to talk about this afternoon
is the research of my doctoral
dissertation and of course you know it's
hard to get the all the research into
afford even do presentations I'm gonna
try to tease out some of the key things
in the presentation and focus a lot on
the results of a presentation and also
providing some things that if you are
involved in any way shape or form in
working with african-americans who of
high blood pressure who might be at risk
there may be some information for during
this presentation that will help you
it's the startling what's in this for me
type question so the title is an
Internet survey investigating
relationships among medication adherence
health status and coping experiences
with racism
pression among hypertensive
african-americans and if you're trying
to wrap your mind around that just think
of medication adherence and coping
skills will try to meijer them together
and as I go through the presentation I
think would come a little clearer you
okay as an introduction I think
regardless of race you know age
ethnicity we know that heart disease and
stroke very common one of the most
common cardiovascular diseases in the
United States as a matter of fact they
are the first and thought leading causes
of death for both men and women in the
United States accounting for more than
thirty five percent of all deaths now
this is not exchanging quite rapidly
when I difference research it was
thirty-five percent it may be a little
higher now but heart disease and stroke
major major diseases regardless of race
or ethnicity so if we look even a little
closer to african-americans African
Americans suffer from it is brought a
level of cardiovascular disease
including high blood pressure so Carly
gossip is a problem for the nation as a
whole but amongst african-americans it
is even more of a greedy aslam the
age-adjusted death rate for heart
disease from 100,000 was 300 points to
rot even Americans compared to two 32.3
for all populations a relative health
expiry of 130 5.3 so what this tells
right off the bat is that
african-americans when it comes to heart
disease and high blood pressure or other
disadvantage there's something happening
that creates a situation where we have
more high blood pressure more
cardiovascular disease than the rest of
the population and we'll get into that a
little bit okay so now that we've
established that cardiovascular disease
and high blood pressure is a problem for
african-americans let's go to some more
of information more information in terms
of things that people are working on
and ways they are trying to reduce the
health disparities and help control
cardiovascular disease what is
medication adherence and medication
adherence plays a role in the higher
levels of cardiovascular morbidity and
mortality experienced by
african-americans and it contributes to
health disparities just as a as a
background medication adherence is
whatever medication you're given taking
it at the right time at the right dose
like you're supposed to that's adherents
proper adherence to medication has been
linked to better health outcomes and
non-adherence has been linked to poor
health outcomes including high matado
rates more hospitalizations so if you
don't take your medication like you
should our poor health outcomes
hospitalization and less poorer our
health outcomes so that's what I'm
medication adherence another item in
this research is that there are now some
emergen theories that racial
discrimination may be contributing
factor to the higher levels of high
blood pressure diagnose soon
african-american so you've heard a lot
about why african-americans of high
blood pressure you know diet insurance
geography but there's some mega theory
that seemed to suggest that the racial
discrimination the stretch from racial
discrimination that I've as experienced
by african-americans on a daily basis
may also be a photo in treating those
high blood pressure numbers secondly the
skills utilized to cope with racial
discrimination may have an impact on
half of african-americans so we know
that stress and racism may contribute to
high blood pressure but the type of
skills utilized by african-americans may
mitigate those high blood pressure
numbers in an instance adaptive coping
skill coping skills
are skills that require you to do things
positively may help reduce your blood
pressure I supposed to negatively which
we my adoptive coping skills which we'll
get into a little bit later okay so we
have identified two things one
medication adherence helps with high
blood pressure to the coping skills also
help with high blood pressure so what we
try to do with this research is to
identify coping strategies associated
with medication adherence so we're
trying to ride the tomb coping
strategies medication adherence what are
some of the be the skills that we need
or that some people have that helps them
with a medication adherence and if we
know these two things we could try to do
is form some intervention programs that
would increase medication adherence by
identifying the type of skills they'll
increase medication adherence so far is
associated with high medication
adherence might facilitate positive
health outcomes for at-risk
african-americans so just a little bit
about study the study investigated
potential relationships between
medication adherence so that's a
demographics like age and gender health
status and instead of measures developed
by the research group on these fridays
at Teachers College Columbia University
some of the key ones which one won't get
into the details our perception of races
in and repression scale when racism and
oppression happen to me scale and the
corporate and responded to racism and
oppression scale in depth scales I can
talk to you you know individual if you
want to know about this skills or
contact the health disparities
department they have these skills are
these new skills that you can get some
information
methodology just we'll just a brief part
about the methodology we use I use an
online survey food sovereignty which is
a a service provider where you can put
your questionnaires or your surveys
online enough and how folks respond to
your questionnaire online it focused on
hypertensive African Americans
regardless of country of all prior birth
and there were laptop computers place in
our adult community health center in
Northeast Philadelphia how we got to
this initially we had done a list of
african-american internet users and got
the survey sent it out to that list will
you get a good response from that so we
wound up doing was locating an adult
human health and in Northeast
Philadelphia and those of our computers
went home and they were able to respond
to the survey those who do not have
computers we provided computers at the
health center for them to go on and
complete the survey that we had
available for that okay just a general
awesome John information about the
numbers that we got we got down 189
participants who completed the survey
and 134 that met the inclusion criteria
by indicating that they were taking
medication for hypertension and answer
the medical adherence question so our
final sample was 134 okay now here's
where I want to spend a little bit of
time in terms of the results our we use
two things one was the morrissey
medication adherence scale which is a
well-known scale used in health
education field to determine medication
adherence so we had us here and then we
took some correlations between the
Medicare the more risky medication
adherence here
it's letter demographics but long with a
new set of measures developed by the
research group comprised in healthcare I
Teachers College to identify meaningful
relationships those I mentioned in the
earlier a bunch of new measures that I
mentioned it earlier on so we try to get
coalition between parents and some of
these stairs in terms of how
african-americans receive racism what
they think about it how the response
awake and hear some of the results some
of them are pretty clear about some of
them I have to spin a little bit more
because these are some of the skills
that we use the measures use from the
research group but columbia mall it's
medication adherence and age and i think
this is a pretty understandable that
there was a significant positive
correlation between medication adherence
and age which means the older the the
participants the more likely the war to
get her into the medication I think
that's pretty sort of intuitive because
when you're little younger you may not
think you need medication you may feel
invincible but as you get older there's
more for a thought-out process to make
sure you do take your medication so as
age went up adherence went to medication
adherence and adaptive cognitive
responses now an adoptive cognitive
response is when you when there's stress
or that's resourcing that you see or you
feel you analyze the situation you see
the positive sides excuse me you say
things out lovely or you are silently
and calm down that's adaptive cognitive
responses it's using things with your
mind to analyze see things for rushil
writes things out and there were in
terms of the study we found out that
there was a significant negative
correlation between medication adherence
adaptive cognitive responses which means
are the more the participants to use
adaptive cognitive responses the less
adherent the word to the medication and
what might be happening and this is this
conjecture what may be happening is
people who analyze the situation what
caused this high blood pressure what was
the stress or the reason that I
experienced causing the high blood
pressure when they analyzed least in
considered positive side of things they
may not want to take their medication
they may want to reel you know
rationalize and find out what happened
to me how can I find other ways to
combat this stretch or racism and hence
they will use less medication other
exalts medication adherence and animal
household income there was a significant
negative correlation between medication
adherence and an enhance or income once
again in this particular regard the hub
in comes the less apparent to the
medication which means folks who are you
know working odd hours you know had
higher incomes probe had good insurance
were less likely to get her to the
medication whereas if you have a lower
income and you know you know if you get
sick and you miss rocky don't get paid
you're more likely to be adherence to
medication so I know household incomes
are there's a negative correlation
between that and medication adherence
the next one is medication adherence and
a perception of that's all racism a
perception of racism there was a
significant negative correlation between
medication adherence and a perception of
racism they're sick for us to the point
that if a participant one of the clients
whether you're a doctor a nurse or
caseworker counselor if your clients
perceive that you are racist they will
not listen to what you have to say so if
your doctor recommends a medication for
a patient or you recommend some advice
for eviction and they perceive that
you're a racist they will not take your
redic recommend
hence the negative correlation so when
there's that perception there they will
not listen to advice that you give it to
them in terms of medication adherence
when the participants bc perceive that
there was racism there were less likely
to be a hurry to their medication okay I
think that goes not only for medication
adherence or anything else that we're
trying to do in working with our clients
if there's a perception that they think
you might be racist your advice may be
falling on deaf ears so we need to make
sure that even in our dealings with our
clients and even if exception of racism
does not exist two more medication
adherence and adopted spiritual
responses there was a significant
negative relationship between medication
adherence and adopted spiritual
responses and add Arctic spiritual
response is a person who'll turn to
prayer or taunt taunt of God or a
spiritual source for guidance so there
was a negative relationship the people
who are more likely to talk to prayer to
turn to God to time to to Tonto
spiritual sauce well next like it to be
adherent to their medication once again
it goes to sort of people who feel that
you know my faith gods in control thing
to take care of themselves may be less
likely to be adherent to the medication
and we as a health educators and I can
say whatever you are where you practice
whether it's a hospital a case work of
social work or just a counselor needs
take into consideration the differences
in people there are some people who
based on their faith that do not want to
take that much medication you have to
find out you have to find a way to reach
them where they are I think like lepers
mentioned little earlier it's not an a
over B you don't tell them what to do
you work with them based on their faith
what they know and help them to get to
the point where you can explain to them
it's okay to be spiritual but if you
have high blood pressure then you need
to take some medication an example would
be a person of faith who says you know
my faith I'm going to pray about it and
you know my bro pressure might go away
you as a counselor if you know where
they stand you know about the faith talk
about the faith and the worst part of it
they have a plot to play to reduce their
medication I their hypertension if the
prey or mon can do it by all means
encourage them if Tony to spiritual
source can do it encourage them but if
they're not controlled on their just
that they need to take their medication
and be adherent the next one is the
adherence and health status there was a
significant positive correlation between
medication and parents and overall
health status which seems to make sense
that if you're healthy you're more
likely to be taking your medication so
adherents which one comes first we don't
know whether you're hearing first on
become healthy or you're healthy because
you're taking your medication that's the
chicken or the egg but once again people
who have an overall health stars are
more likely to medicate to be adherent
to their medication okay medication
adherence and skills to cope with racism
there was a significant positive
correlation between medication adherence
and skills adaptive skills needed to
cope with racism so as an example
somebody who feels discriminated against
and hopeful about their Theresa saying
if they have skills adaptive skills
they've found ways to cope with the
races in whether it's like raining
exercising laughing they found ways to
deal with the reaches in and tackling
they're more likely to take their
medication where I someone who cannot
cope with the racism does not have those
adaptive skills for the races in may not
take their medication so the skills that
we that the adaptive skills i think was
mentioned earlier adaptive skills not
getting I'm really not blowing your top
trying to find a way to cope with the
situation those types types of cells
reduce the blood pressure and very often
they help a person becoming more
inherent to their medication in this
medication and the quality of care there
was a significant
positive correlation between Medicare
between many medical requirements and
quality of health care provided once
again when a client whether it's in a
hospital or like I just mentioned a
community health center when they
believe that getting a good quality of
care that usually are looking up for
them to give them good quality care
they're more likely to believe what
you're saying and when you recommend
something in this case medication then
they will take their medication and I
think that's very important in terms of
especially physicians and nurses and
those who are in hospitals is that the
perception that your patients or your
plants have all of you impacts how they
take their medication or how they
respond or follow through on what you
tell them to do if they perceive that
you're racist if they perceive that
you're giving them poor quality care if
they perceive that you don't care you
will not get the medication adherence
and hence you might be hard difficulty
in convincing these patients to do what
might be in the best interest okay I
think this is the last in terms of the
results it's medication adherence and
adaptive behavior responses an adaptive
behavior response is when a person who
is faced with racism or the oil pressure
when they speak up assertively when they
talk with optimistic friends over there
relax in a part or God or notion they
take a behavior they do something when
they see that when they experience this
racism and once again a process who is
more likely to speak up when there's
racism talk with optimistic friends to
get encouraged or relax they found a way
to cope with this racism and when you
find a way to cope with it you're more
likely to do the things that are quite
for you either to take your medication
or to get better and once again people
who don't speak up for who don't have
those behavioral skills make the
institution where they have talked to
negative friends and have not found a
way to deal with the situation and in
terms of
it's a medical advice taking medication
or doing other things they may not want
to take those from avias okay so what we
did we looked at a number of variables
number of variables and you picked up
all there was a we did a correlation to
pick up the major predictors of
medication adherence remember the very
beginning we said medication adherence
and has a key impact on health outcomes
in terms of high blood pressure so wanna
see what are the key predictors of
medication adherence what types of
either demographics or behaviors will
lead to medication adherence if we can
identify what these I've we can write a
two-week an English medication adherence
and then be able to reduce high blood
pressure up with the high risk
african-americans here's what we found
one of the first indicators was not
having a partner and that might be a
little counterintuitive because we think
that you know when you have a partner
you're more likely to get herring the
group that we that we saw it was from
adult community center in philadelphia
most of the participants who are older
and there were females which means over
the years they may have lost their
partner may be due to divorce or death
so these are older females who are very
uncaring hence the data make a little
suit because the people we started were
a little older because a lot of data
suggests with a partner you're more
hearing or with this particular book
that we started there were older females
would not have a partner and they were
here hence we got this data that not
having a partner is a significant
predictor another one is not being
employed are once again folks who are
employing and maybe you know wanting to
walk down so many things may affect them
taking their medication right those
right time right place because they're
doing so many things they may not have
the opportunity to take their medication
like they should but those who are not
employed who are not going to work but
spend the time in the morn oh and the
afternoon when even Sigmund medication
exactly when it was needed better health
serves better health service once again
with significant predictors as it would
better health status or more likely to
be medicated out to be the adherent to
the medication once again we're under
which comes first are they adherent
hence they are better health status or
the other way around but what this
suggests to us once again as if they are
good that's good emotional health good
physical health put coping skills that's
likely to lead to adherence and taking
actions that will help with high blood
pressure more seals to cope with racism
I think I thrust upon us a little
earlier those who have developed
adaptive skills to cope with racism
where the adoptive cognitive skills
spiritual skills those who are those
type of sauce or more likely to do
something about their hypertension and
such as taking their medication so
there's a deserve as called upon the
correlation between having those skills
and taking their medication the last two
are less psychological disturbance which
means those who have a better emotional
health are better will cope with the
situation the stress and the visions and
racism that they're facing so they are
less psychological disturbance better
emotional health are more likely to try
to do something with the high blood
pressure such as taking their medication
so unless psychological disturbance was
a predictor of medication adherence and
the last one is a fewer adaptive as
behavioral skills fewer adaptive
behavioral skills which means we talk
about behavioral adapted behavioral
skills those who behave in a way such
that when they stress or racism they
either speak up they go to a pond they
do something they were off or change
those who have those skills
those are those types of skills are more
likely to do something about their blood
pressure and hence take their medication
with fewer skills few adaptive skills
don't stick up don't try to speak up
golden days try to get to a calm place
do yoga those are a few of those cells
don't have the main on how the skills
required they have to mitigate their
blood pressure hence may depend on
medication a lot more they are fewer
skills to cope with their blood pressure
so they go to medication a little bit
more than somebody what some of these
seals who make exercise for both world
wars to cop or do something along those
lines okay in conclusion cardiovasc
raucous parties that be reduced and very
slowly at best and some cases even
getting worse at the very beginning I
said very often we talk about
african-americans and having high blood
pressure may think oh maybe it's
insurance its diet it's exercise so
there are many many good theories out
there and many many good armed
intervention programs out there but if
the pro if the problem is getting worse
we might be missing something so I think
part of what we're trying to do is bring
some new and innovative ideas if we can
find out what are some of the behavior
traits of people that will make them my
parent if we can talk to them about you
know their spirituality or their
thinking or their behaviors if we can
understand them and find out where they
are in terms of those types of behaviors
we may be able to relate to them better
they may listen to us a little bit more
and be more apparent to the medication
if we meet them as partners and talk to
them as partners I supposed to telling
them what to do patients no longer I
want to be told do not want to be told
take this medication that's all you need
to know nothing else you need to relate
to them find out what makes them tick
quote unquote so if you can do that you
can relate to them connect with them
they're more likely to listen to you and
be adherent to them
vacation so this goes to the second
bullet that there's a need for health
education health educators and have
education researchers develop new and
innovative programs to reduce
disparities and like I mentioned the
group on health as far as at Columbia
University Teachers College has some of
these some of these newer cells that
that we use in this particular study and
these cells that helps identify the type
of behavior traits that people have when
we can do that we can relate to them
better and help them with a medication
adherence it is a complex relationship
between medication adherence and coping
skills but I think with the new skills
that are being developed and will be
some of the newer research that were
looking into that we can find a way to
marry coping skills and medication
adherence hence how african-americans
who are at risk do a better job of
coping with their with with racism and
stress and oppression and to average of
taking their medications and reducing
the high blood pressure hence reducing
health disparities I think that is my
last slide so have any questions or
comments yes please
yes
this some of the we have one of the
skills as when racism and oppression
happens to me scale it is a question
that do you know when it's happening to
you so any in that particular survey
pick patients are clans what are the
participants were asked about these
questions and they will say yes I know
what's happening to me so it's one of
those sales that I was just talking
about those measures of talking about it
asks that question with a bunch of
questions and they said yes I know
what's happened to me will happen to
others yes please yes
one of the one of the earlier questions
after our demographics was so many
questions that where do you rate your
health how do you show how do you feel
in terms of these specific wording in
terms of how do you rate your health are
you healthy do you think you have good
health oh yeah the like of scale you
know you're very healthy not as healthy
so the participants indicated where they
thought the health was yeah deficit yes
please I very interesting presentation
thank you um I got a little bit lost
though in some times you had an inverse
relationship between adaptive coping
responses and medication kicks and
sometimes that was a positive
relationship and I they may have been
different kinds of coping okay sure in
terms of coping skills overall coping
skills it is a positive correlation
between coping skills medication
adherence not only with racism yes yes
those are the seals that cope with the
racism I different whether it was
adopted cognitive adaptive spiritual
overall bring all these coping skills
together overall coping skills on a way
to cope with the racism or more likely
to be my parent to their medications but
when you bring down to specifics in
terms of you pull a particular one are
like spiritual now I'm give an inverse
relationship but when you put them as a
whole overall coping skills as a
positive correlation oh okay okay well
you are yes your data
point for some insight in terms of
implications for secondary prevention
what do you think based on what you
found could be some implications for
primary terms of dealing with and coping
with racism before the baby photos
become hypotensive I think in general
one of the things that we can we can
take a look at is in terms of just
learning some stress management some
coping skills before we get to that
point i think was mentioned earlier on
if something happens to you can you get
angry or do you lash out in terms of
response those types of behaviors people
getting angry or getting impatient thank
God for us mention something this
morning but me the exact example but
those types of behaviors camp can
prevent us from having high blood
pressure I think very often I think not
very often but in many cases high blood
pressure is a result of pressure tension
stress due to either racism or anger or
those are the types of things if we can
try to begin to educate people in terms
of using better coping skills for
everyday problems everyday stresses and
that may prevent us from getting to the
point where we have hypertension and
need medication yes please
because we personally I have
hypertension and even though i do take
my medication and I'm John watchful eye
he and I you know healthy and mine is
the slaw and so forth
and spiritual it's not decreasing that's
all I keep saying are you still eating
project not for all your teams you know
i'm watching
and this bears over tryna day we're
trying to make this part of our to add
to the intervention yes as a medication
yes increase include to use your words
and there's the diet but there may be
some other things involved that I going
on that when you take a look at that we
can find ways to work on those other
things in terms of coping skills that
may go a long way and helping us have
better health outcomes so could you just
go through a list like just identified
five implications for someone just like
her okay let's see five implications
okay one of the things that you could I
think you said to trying to be more
spiritual so that could be one in terms
of you know you know looking either
inside or looking for some some divine
source you know if you're a Christian or
if you're Muslim or fury of the Jewish
faith look to your fate as a way to deal
with problems that you will get better
that's that could be one of them are
behavioral responses one of things that
you could do in terms of behaviors speak
up assertively in cases where there's
racism I talked to positive friends you
could do that you know go you know go to
the beach take a walk those types of
things that come something you could
also do as well cognitive in terms of
when you do experience you know some
racism that they may be pushing your
blood pressure analyze the situation
think about it okay what happened here
what can I do next time how can I make
changes to avoid that situation that
just created this and these are my being
upset so that's really a look at it
differently for example acceptance okay
so okay oh so many things are going to
happen in life you know and we can't
control every single thing we try to
control as much as we can so any things
we have to accept and find alternate
ways I guess to do with those particular
situations it's going to happen this is
going to happen I need to accept it and
find another way to cope with it I can't
fight this particular thing this is a
war I need to accept it me try and fight
oh we go around the war all over the
world you know what do you mean
underneath they accept this particular
situation which I cannot change which
i'm not going to knock my head against
all the time because it's not going to
change i'm going to accept this
particular situation and find all the
ways to get around it okay okay well the
normal questions thank you very much
okay um therefore for a moment I'm
extremely proud of you of course I'll
mention you so that you changes a few
things in your language work which we're
kind of related to the question i think
that from from the back but I now see my
you returned to become a professor and
to leave your lucrative but a
pharmaceutical second appointment
because i think that i am just so glad I
had this opportunity to hear you
elaborate when you have an oral defense
of a dissertation they say completions
talk about it in seven to twelve
business and so you've never get an
opportunity to really hear this kind of
elaboration which is what was so
wonderful about hearing shameless
here Sheila said I'm talking about my
dissertation oh no no no she was talking
about focus groups and interviews that
she conducted that are technically even
before or dissertation and so I'm just
so proud of both of you that you really
have opportunity to go into detail and
you know both of you why levy in terms
of you dr. daramola it's just so
exciting to see how when you got
released from that pressure I had you
under my on your back yeah yes I'm
really blossom thank you and it's just
really a pleasure it's such a reward to
see that the the stress involved
impressions some lunch and pushing
someone to reach their highest potential
then you say bye-bye and then they just
keep on reaching their eyes and highest
potential so it's just it's just so
gratifying and i look forward to Shayla
just taking off like a rocket after may
2009 and we have to give now I know he's
on your Jeep they figured out how to
deal with his long man sings now about
your PR other recent graduate who we
really have to thank and honor for
putting such an effort into bringing out
the most undergraduate students to
expose them to mentor me and i will say
that dr. terrible is a close second
for me and see what she stays by
allowing us to mentor individuals as
early as undergraduate year the
preceding program was brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at itunes TC
columbia edu